president biden is launching a public
campaign for a massive social spending
bill and working behind the scenes to
make it smaller he told union workers in
michigan yesterday that republicans who
oppose the plan are putting the
country's future at stake the president
is also telling fellow democrats that
the multi-trillion dollar plan will have
to be cut by more than one-third ed
o'keefe is at the white house ed good
morning
nate good morning to you it does seem
that after weeks of very public
disagreement over the size and scope of
the president's plan democrats may now
be rallying about around a new
less expensive price
on the road in michigan president biden
argued the trillions of dollars in new
federal spending will help maintain
america's competitive edge these bills
are about competitiveness
versus complacency
a new poll shows a majority of americans
support the democratic push for more
federal spending on child care
education
family tax breaks
and expanding medicare for seniors but
with members of the president's own
party disagreeing about the scope of his
plan he's now telling them aim for
roughly two trillion dollars in new
federal spending
it's not going to be 3.5 trillion it's
going to be less than that
that new price range just might be
enough to win over west virginia senator
joe manchin a key holdout i'm not ruling
anything out but the bottom line is i
want to make sure what you're teaching
it's unclear how the proposed buildback
better plan could be shrunk but a group
of house democrats told the president
tuesday they want to enact new climate
change protections paid family leave
universal pre-k and extend child tax
credits and then there's the debt limit
america's bills come due on october 18th
but republicans say democrats can raise
the borrowing limit on their own they've
had plenty of time
to execute
the debt ceiling
increase
raising the debt limit pays for past
spending and democrats note the national
debt jumped nearly 8 trillion dollars
during the trump administration mostly
thanks to republican-backed tax cuts for
higher income americans if republicans
would just get out of the damn way we
could get this all done
the next step in the debt ceiling fight
comes later today when senate democrats
try to hold another vote to try to raise
the limit but that's going to require
republican consent that's unlikely and
it means they'll likely once again
invoke the filibuster that prompted the
president last night for the first time
to suggest it may be time to rewrite
senate rules and get rid of the
filibuster at least when it comes to
votes over the debt limit he'll also
meet later today gail with business
leaders to discuss the dangers of
failing to increase the nation's
borrowing limit
all right ed thank you very much